the concourse delegate at the villa
desta on lake como is one of the world's
leading and most long-standing classic
car events
you will never see so many beautiful
cars so many passionate people
despite the weather this is the best
place to be
says that sitting in a car like this
lagonda makes him feel like the great
gatsby adding that you rarely see cars
like this on the street
mata says the place to see them is at
premier classic car shows like the
concourse delegates villadesta on lake
como
it's a perfect place for a brand like
aston martin to celebrate special
birthdays
the british sports car maker would have
turned 100 this year the aston martins
here are all privately owned
these wheels would be a credit to any
factory museum the high-class owners
show typically high-class reserve
more than 50 classic cars can be seen
here all of them are worth millions
artworks on wheels
the undisputed star of the show is this
1938 bugatti 57 sc atlantic only four of
the streamlined cars were ever built one
fetched more than 23 million euros at
auction in 2010 making it one of the
world's most expensive cars this one
belongs to fashion designer ralph lauren
i love beautiful cars
whether they're very modern or very or
old
contemporary or pre-war but i love all
cars
a spectacular example of a car from the
roaring 20s is this sky blue open tour
with a design based on the 1928
rolls-royce phantom 1 and a 7.7 liter
engine under the hood
the owner alexander shelfler says the
concourse is his favorite show after
pebble beach it's the world's second
best classic event and certainly the
best in europe you meet nice people and
see cars it's a great honor to be
invited
points out that alongside the classics
are visionary concept cars like the
grand lusso the result of a bmw and
pininfarina cooperation
bmv and pininfarina
this glimpse of the future not only left
us thinking of a new series of coupes
but bmw as well
kareem habib tells us the car is a grand
lusso
and as the name implies it's about gt or
gran turismo and grand luzo or luxury
he adds that the design philosophy is of
course dynamic after all it's a bmw so
it's sporty but it's also elegant safe
and flawless with lines running from
front to back
two-wheelers are also welcome at the
concourse deleganza bmw is using its
event patronage to celebrate 90 years of
bmw bikes
few concept studies are a must
bmw says the brand represents
functionality and performance he notes
however that precision and emotion also
go with the bike which many people may
not expect from bmw he says it's
especially pleasing to him that the
motorcycle is so well received
the concept 90 model makes an optical
reference to the 1973 bmw r90s it's to
be produced in series with similar lines
on the second day of the event the cars
cruise over to the nearby villa alba
where the public is invited to join in
classy car enthusiasts are thrilled
worldwide he adds they knew they had to
come and now they're here saying the
cars are out of their price range but
it's nice to see them anyway
the cars the atmosphere it's a great day
this man enthuses
the high point of judging in the contest
for the best looking car
is the stroll or drive by to have a look
the prices can increase the value of the
automobile enormously
the rolls-royce open touring drives off
with a trophy and value-added as well
ralph lauren's bugatti wins the gold cup
at the 2013 concourse of delegates as
everyone expected
mata says it might be an idea to drop in
on the next concourse if you happen to
be in the lake cuomo area sometime in
late may it's a place to see wonderful
cars and have interesting conversations
and he's off to do just that right now
you